there's a lot to get to today a major
supreme court ruling
on religious liberty some shocking new
evidence presented at a pennsylvania
hearing
over potential election fraud
but all of that pales in comparison to
the most important news story that the
mainstream media
are bringing to you joe biden's cat
and now some breaking news
president-elect joe biden and his wife
jill
won't just be bringing their german
shepherds major and champ to the white
house
the bidens tell us exclusively that
soon they'll be joined by a cat by the
way the real reason that joe biden needs
a cat
is that his dog is threatening his life
and breaking his bones that is true not
a very auspicious start for the alleged
biden
presidency i'm michael knowles the
michael knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from last
wednesday it has been so long i hope you
all had a happy thanksgiving
and are having a very happy cyber monday
i hope you're getting daily wire
subscriptions on cyber monday
but my favorite comment from last
wednesday from christopher rodriguez who
says biden is going to replace his
come on man with i carumba that's true
icaru or desposito
because he's going to have to get his
numbers up among latino voters
among black voters among a whole lot of
voters he's doing very well among dead
voters but among other sorts of voters
it's sort of up in the air speaking of
people that we want to remember
legacy box is a safe and affordable way
to digitally preserve
all your home movies and photos that are
currently trapped on dated formats like
vhs or film
with everything that's going on here is
a great way to ensure
the focus remains on your family this
holiday season
so many of us have irreplaceable moments
on tapes and film
that we can no longer watch this this
happened to me and i'll give you a very
sad example
a beloved family member who died i had
all of these photographs in one place
and then i lost them and i lost them
before i had legacy box
fortunately i did find some more photos
immediately send them to legacy box i'm
so glad
that they are now preserved forever they
can help you discover what's on all
those tapes and films maybe you don't
even know what's on them anymore
and keep the footage organized and save
for years to come once you have those
digital versions you can relax knowing
they're secure for generations
legacy box is something you can order in
minutes and enjoy
forever this is the best deal of the
year right now go to legacybox.com
knowlescanwles
take advantage of this limited time
offer get 60 percent
off do it you will not regret it i'm so
putting my memories on legacy box is one
of the best things i did last year
this exclusive offer won't last long
order your kit now they send it to you
whenever you're ready it is a sale to
remember sixty percent off while
supplies last
go to legacy box dot com slash knowledge
can interview l-e-s
lots of those relatives who may have
passed on to remember some of whom may
have voted in the presidential election
and yet the story that we're hearing
from the mainstream media is about
joe biden's pets this is the kind of
hard-hitting journalism that you can
expect if joe biden does in fact
ascend to the presidency which very
likely will know within a couple of
weeks
when the electors vote on december 14th
but the cat story actually does have
a serious aspect to it which is that joe
biden has some dogs
and he was playing with his dogs and he
had a fall
and if he were a younger man that
wouldn't be a big deal but because he's
exceedingly frail and elderly
this fall was very very serious as nbc
news reports
uh joe biden just left an orthopedic
office in delaware
where he was treated for a sprained
right ankle after this fall on saturday
it looks like he's got
a fracture um in his in his foot
and so probably the cat is a little bit
more his speed than the dog this is very
sad i'm actually i'm not making fun of
joe biden
i do not wish him ill i do not wish him
broken bones
i think it is very sad for him and it's
very sad for the country
that potentially we will have a frail
president who is not up for the job
who should be in retirement after
50 years of living off public corruption
that would be much much better
uh president trump responding to this by
the way he tweets that he just says
get well soon you know trump i guess
it's a nice thing for him to say
but what he's pointing out is i'm very
energetic
my opponent is frail and elderly
that is the point that he's making he's
been making this point for a very long
time he's been making it ever since he
said he was a young
and vibrant man which of these guys is
the president-elect
we don't know according to the media joe
biden is basically already the president
forget about the inauguration forget
about the electors voting the guy is
already in office
and according to trump supporters a
great many of them something like 71
the election was illegitimate the
election was stolen and a great many of
those people think that president trump
is the president-elect we have something
like
schrodinger's cat we have schrodinger's
president
schroeder we are in a state of quantum
politics
where both of these guys simultaneously
appear to be the president-elect the
schrodinger's cat for those of you who
don't remember all the way back to
eighth grade
when this science thought experiment was
brought up to us
it is uh this this thought experiment
whereby you've got a cat in a box
and you've got a poison that will be
released based on a random quantum event
and uh without going too much into
uh this scientific theory that i don't
even really understand myself
the question is when does a quantum
system
stop existing as this superposition of
states
all these multiple states at one time
and collapse into one
distinct reality when does it stop being
the case that joe biden and donald trump
are both the president-elect according
to a great many people in the country
both of these probabilities existing at
once when does it collapse into
who will be the president well if you
ask
president trump i i guess it would be
december 14th except he was just asked
by a reporter
if the electors vote for joe biden on
december 14th
will you concede his answer a little
ambiguous
it's going to be a very hard thing to
concede because we know there was
massive fraud
so as to whether or not i can get this
apparatus moving this quickly
because time isn't on our side
everything else is on our side facts are
on our side
this was a massive fraud this should
never take place in this country we're
like a third world country
we have machines that nobody knows what
the hell they're looking at i mean you
take a look at all the mistakes they
made
look at even georgia look at all the
mistakes they made and that all that was
as simple you press a button
look at look at george all the all the
votes they found just by going
and i said they shouldn't even do it
because it doesn't mean anything
they're doing a recount right now in
georgia that is meaningless
the only recount that matters in georgia
is to look at the signatures on the
envelope
and you will find that those signatures
do not match the people that were many
of them
hundreds of thousands of them hundreds
of thousands and i only lost by twelve
thousand votes
i didn't lose i didn't even like the
satellites okay so you you see the point
here president trump saying i don't know
it's a hard thing to concede
now i don't think that president trump
is going to declare a military
dictatorship
you know and uh martial law if the
electors
vote for biden on december 14th but he's
not conceding yet
nor should he according to the media
it's clear
donald trump lost he lost by a lot oh
there's not too much evidence of fraud
oh forget about georgia forget about
pennsylvania
that's all bunk there is a lot of
evidence
of what we call irregularities and
maybe we should use a harsher term even
than irregularities
there was no reason if everything was
above board there was no reason to stop
the vote counting
at 10 30 at night on election night in
certain highly
democratic democratically controlled
precincts
okay there was no reason to do that
there was especially no reason as we saw
in georgia
to then surreptitiously restart the
counting at one in the morning when
there were no poll watchers around
whatsoever
there was no reason for the democratic
machine cities
to prevent republican poll watchers from
watching the count there was especially
no reason
for those same democratically run cities
to ignore a court order demanding that
republican poll watchers watch the count
there was no reason to do any of that if
everything was above
board but maybe everything was not above
board
we're being told by the media there's no
evidence that
there was any fraud in this election
obviously we've gone through
quite a bit of that evidence on this
show
but we saw some more evidence of that
last week last week during a
pennsylvania hearing
on some of the irregularities here you
had a data specialist
kind of colonel phil waldron make even
more explosive claims than any of the
evidence we've been discussing on this
show
phil waldron claimed that the election
software that was used all around this
country
in great many places was built to be
hacked
the voting systems in the u.s and in
pennsylvania were built to be
manipulated
they've been used in elections around
the world and stolen elections
around the world in venezuela italy
argentina singapore
bolivia as close as two weeks ago
the philadelphia uses esns pittsburgh
uses dominion
other counties in pennsylvania use
dominion
and other systems so what's what's the
real deal
so all these election systems have a
common dna
uh sgo smartmatic sold sequoia voting
systems to dominion in 2010
and then the divold company spun off
premier election systems to dominion
as a result of an anti-trust suit i know
there's been statements
to the contrary but i personally
debriefed the son of a cuban
intelligence officer
who had first-hand knowledge of hugo
chavez's family members who told him
not to worry about the populist threat
against maduro's election in venezuela
quote unquote that it was guaranteed
their father invested the money to build
the sgo
voting machine system so i had no reason
to doubt this gentleman he's
sworn an affidavit to this effect these
are pretty explosive claims
and before the media write this guy off
as some total kook who heard this from a
guy
and a guy and he's the dry cleaner of
the cousin of you know
this is a serious person this colonel
phil waldron
talking about serious people cuban
intelligence officers we know there's a
very tight relationship
between cuban intelligence and venezuela
particularly under
hugo chavez these claims are that
through various companies various sales
of companies there has been
some association between the different
election
software companies here notably dominion
and
that it was possible for the election to
have been hacked
that the that in a certain sense these
machines were built
such that the election could have been
hacked dominion of course denies
all of this i think it's pretty clear
that this guy's showing vulnerabilities
he's showing
he actually flat out states that the
devices are connected to the internet so
they have
at least the logical possibility of
being hacked the problem here though
with running out of time as president
trump pointed out is the trump team
needs to provide proof
not merely that this could happen but
that it did happen
and i know it's very very difficult to
provide that proof
even if it did happen around the country
even if millions of votes were shifted
it would be very difficult to find the
proof of that but the trump team needs
to provide the proof of that
or and this is just a purely descriptive
matter the courts are not going to
overthrow the election
and and frankly even the state
legislatures are not going to
flip the certification or refuse to
certify in the places that they haven't
it just won't happen they need to
provide the proof that it did
happen now look there is evidence we're
being told
there's no evidence of anything and even
let's forget about the poll watchers for
a second
there's no evidence that there were any
irregularities because of the voting
machines or batches of votes coming in
bs there's a ton of evidence of that in
fact colonel waldron points out that
there was a massive
vote dump while there have been massive
vote dumps a number of places
with statistical anomalies one of which
showed that
more than 99 of the ballots in one dump
went to joe biden normally you would
expect to see
a smooth curve going up not any uh
not any big big spikes uh that's kind of
what uh what greg was talking about the
the anomalies of loading and uploading
those uh those votes so that big spike
that uh occurs there is a prime
indicator of
fraudulent voting and that's 604 000
votes
in 90 minutes is that right correct this
is
uh 337 votes
337 000 votes in that
in that period of time yes and when you
look at this entire
curve with all these spikes
can you calculate how how much of a vote
that accounted for for biden
and how much for trump close to six
hundred thousand i think our
our figures are about 570 some odd
thousand that uh
all those spikes represent over time for
but correct
and how much for trump i think it was a
little over 3200
570 000 for biden
3 000 for trump which means that in that
batch that came in
joe biden received 99.4
of the vote we got to congratulate joe
biden joe biden managed to outperform
saddam hussein at the height of his
power in iraq
in certain voting batch dumps
in certain counties in america wow
good job joe here i thought that there
was very little enthusiasm for joe
biden's candidacy turns out
he does better numbers than a middle
eastern dictator does he or maybe maybe
not maybe he doesn't
maybe that's statistically impossible
now we have we have so much of this
evidence and yet
if you can't prove that it was done not
merely that it could be done
not merely that the statistics point to
that it was done if you can't prove that
it was
done then all of this evidence in a buck
50 is going to get us
a buck or rather it's going to get us a
cup of coffee
even on cyber monday with all these
great deals you know speaking of these
great deals
the holidays are here this year you got
to give yourself some extra money in
your pocket
you can pay off your credit card
balances and save with a credit card
consolidation loan
from light stream roll your high
interest credit card payments into just
one payment at a lower fixed rate
light streams credit card consolidation
loans have rates as low as 5.95
apr with auto pay and excellent credit
you can get a loan from 5 000 to 100
000 plus absolutely no fees no
application fees no origination fees no
transaction fees no prepayment penalties
i know there are all these little fees
that the companies always add in
not here you can even get your money as
soon as the day
that you apply i have seen friends and
family members
ruin their financial lives because of
crippling credit card debt in particular
do not do that be smart don't throw
money out the window my listeners can
save
even more by the way with an additional
interest rate discount the only way
to get this discount is to go to
lightstream.com
knowles canada l e s l i g h t
s t r e a m dot com slash
knowles subject to credit approval rates
range from 5.95
apr to 19.99 apr and include a 0.50 auto
pay discount lowest rate requires
excellent credit terms and conditions
apply
it offers your subject to change without
notice visit lightstream.com slash
knowles can interview l-e-s
for more information
now there is some hope out of the courts
i think again it's probably unlikely
that the courts are going to grow enough
of a spine
to decertify election results to
halt the end of this election however
there is some good news
in georgia there was an emergency order
just sent in by
judge timothy batten senior which
will prevent election officials from
wiping or resetting
any voting machines in the state of
georgia until further order of the court
this is very important because if there
were anomalies on these voting machines
you want to at least
preserve the computers so that you might
have some evidence maybe you don't even
have evidence after that but at the very
least this judge thinks
that there is enough evidence that there
was tampering in the voting machines in
georgia
that we need to stop those voting
machines from being wiped
or reset again is that going to be
enough
i'm skeptical i'm skeptical that that
will be enough unless you can provide
hard proof i think that these judges
are going to not want to be seen as
interfering in the political process
throwing an election and unfortunately
the process may play out as president
trump says
time is running out there's still a
little bit of time but it's about 14
days left where we're
suspended in this quantum state where
we've got potentially two presidents
elect
now there is some good good news coming
out of the supreme court as well which
is that the supreme court defended
religious liberty well that's a good
thing especially if we are
headed for a joe biden presidency which
i hope that we are not and i still hold
out some hope that we are not but if we
are
religious liberty is going to come under
grave attack joe biden already sued
nuns when he was vice president during
the obama administration
sued nuns because they wouldn't pay for
abortion drugs he's promising to do so
again these democratic tyrants around
the country
are encouraging people to go out and
protest for blm and steal gucci bags and
sneakers
but they are shutting down churches well
the supreme court said no to that in a
5-4
ruling on wednesday night the supreme
court backed a religious challenge to
andrew cuomo's restrictions of churches
and synagogues in new york cuomo's been
particularly bad about this
the devout catholic andrew cuomo of
similar devotion
to the devout catholic joe biden who by
the way doesn't even know
simple books of the bible which we'll
get to in a little bit
the supreme court came out and said no
you can't shut down these places you
can't shut down
the synagogues and you can't shut down
the churches
a lot of other places are open in this
country but for some reason democratic
governors
have had a real problem with the
churches and the synagogues and the
reason for this by the way the
the charitable read of why they want to
keep those shut down
is that they think that religion is
superfluous it's ridiculous it's
silly that people still go to church
they don't believe in
any of the things that are
that go on in churches and synagogues
these democratic secularists think it's
all superstition
they believe that religious people are
superstitious ironically irreligious
people are much more superstitious
which we recently found out also thanks
to the mainstream media
but they believe there's no reason to
risk people's lives it's very important
that people go protest for blm
that's important to the human spirit and
to our body politic
but it's not important that they go
worship this crazy old man in the sky
with a beard as they describe
god as no one else describes god in
history but as liberal atheists do and
so they want to keep that shut down well
the supreme court says no
this is very important the closure of
these churches from the beginning was
always outrageous
we never should have tolerated it
there is a scientific argument to keep
the churches open as well i don't really
care to make scientific arguments that
the only language that the left speaks
is
scientific with a capital s which does
not refer really to
physical science but it refers to their
religion of secularism
of course their their love of science
doesn't apply when men pretend that they
can become women
or when activists pretend that babies
are not human so it isn't
even scientific in the narrow physical
sense but when they invoke science
they're invoking their own secular
religion
and it's important to point out to these
left-wingers that even by
their own premises that you know we need
to preserve our life on earth
at all costs it's worth not seeing
anybody it's worth never seeing your
loved ones or your relatives as long as
you can eke out a few more months
on this earth even by that standard
it was wrong to shut down the churches
and the synagogues there's a new
report out from nbc which says hidden in
a pandemic
elderly in nursing homes are dying
from isolation
the people who are in nursing homes well
a lot of elderly in nursing homes were
dying
because andrew cuomo sent sick people
into nursing homes
thousands of elderly new yorkers died
because of that dumb policy but that's
not even what nbc is talking about
nbc is saying that there are people who
are dying of broken hearts
of despair of isolation and of
loneliness in nursing homes
because they can't see their loved ones
and guess who
said that was going to happen from the
beginning all of us
all of the conservatives and when all
the conservatives said hey guys it's
kind of cruel
to lock away elderly people away from
their loved ones for the
for the last months or years of their
life
when we when we said that do you know
what the left called the science deniers
well do you know what we can call we can
call them philosophy deniers we can call
them
theology deniers because man does not
live by bread alone
okay and and life is not just existing
it's not just
being somewhat conscious life is being
social
seeing people that you love pursuing
your
joys having ambition talking to people
enjoying one another's company
nbc writes more than eight months since
the pandemic the very isolation meant to
protect nursing home residents
is also contributing to their deaths
confined to their nursing homes and
largely cut off from visitors
many residents are experiencing mental
and physical decline
gee you don't say you don't say i hope
i've said this many times
especially during the lockdowns i hope
that we can banish the term science
from our political discourse it is a
meaningless term now
science as you know refers to knowledge
that's what
it comes from shire the latin word shire
which means to know
it once meant all knowledge then for the
past couple
few hundred years it has referred very
narrowly to material
inquiry you know physical things not
metaphysical things
then now it it refers to leftist
politics
the science of history the science of
politics the science of progressivism
the left believes they know the way that
history is going to
flow and so anything that they prefer
will be science and therefore outside
the realm of public debate
and anything that disagrees with their
orthodoxy will
is unscientific it's anti-science you're
a science denier well turns out the
left-wing science isn't particularly
scientific
because human beings need more than just
physical things
we do need to see people we do have
hopes and dreams and cares for the for
the materialists who believe that
nothing exists
outside of physical objects like this
microphone or this
leftist tears tumbler which is very
important it has a spiritual quality too
for people who believe that that only
material things exist
how about mathematics mathematics isn't
physical it's metaphysical
ideas loves joys
cares sorrows everything
that really matters to you
not physical perhaps we could focus on
that as well
there's more to life and death than just
life and death
though there was some great news in the
field of death
usually a sort of sad topic to discuss
but there is some good news for justice
because the federal government is now
permitting other forms of the death
penalty
other than lethal injection and i know a
lot of liberals are furious and even
many conservatives are furious
and unfortunately they're all wrong this
is very good news for
justice you know
justice order law
security these are things on which
civilization
rests and you know online it's very
difficult to protect your data security
but you
should the holidays can feel like a
never-ending to-do list there's
shopping online there's there's browsing
that you're going to be doing all the
time scrolling and scrolling all of that
can expose your personal info
so get lifelock identity theft
protection because not all websites are
on the nice
list and you will want to know if your
personal information has been
potentially exposed
or found on the dark web lifelock
helps detect a wide range of identity
threats for instance
this is a top-line one social security
number for sale on the dark web
if they detect your information being
used in their network they will send you
an alert
if you become a victim of identity theft
lifelock can help you restore your
identity
easier than what you can do on your own
it's very simple i know i used to think
no one's after my data
they are no one can prevent
all identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses
but lifelock can help you feel protected
this holiday season
the best sale of the year is happening
right now you can save up to
thirty percent off your first year at
lifelock.com
knowlescanwles that is 30 off at
lifelock.com scannerwles
sale ends november 30th
the left will allow the elderly to die
of loneliness in nursing homes
and that's fine that's wonderful they
celebrate that they demand you let that
happen
but then the left will weep for the
monsters and rapists and murderers
who are getting their just desserts well
beginning on christmas eve the
department of justice will allow the
bureau of prisons
to execute inmates on federal death row
by means other than lethal injection and
i think this is very important
and it's it's a way to show even more
clearly
that the death penalty is not cruel and
unusual punishment because
lethal injection well it's not unusual i
guess it does happen
but i do suspect it's a bit crueler than
other forms
of capital punishment the reason for
this it gets to
what we're talking about how there's
more than
the physical world to our existence
there's no dignity in lethal injection
when a criminal
is lethally injected it's so clinical
it's so you're strapped to the table
you're lying down
it's apparently quite painful sometimes
it often goes wrong
it's just a really vile process but that
does not mean that the death penalty
generally is a vile process there
actually can be dignity in the death
penalty
there's a line from dr johnson who says
when a man knows to he's to be hanged in
a fortnight
it concentrates his mind wonderfully
meaning it can actually help you put
your
your ideas and your soul in order
and then you stand on the scaffold it's
not a pleasant experience
probably but certainly more pleasant
than being strapped down to a gurney and
injected with some painful poison
i've often considered firing squad would
probably be the most
dignified way to go you can go out with
a blindfold
it's sudden you've got a cigarette in
your mouth say
you know i wouldn't prefer it to living
but it's certainly
a more dignified way to go the fact that
now the federal government will permit
these states to use different forms of
the death penalty
i think is important one the death
penalty itself is
morally justifiable and and
there's a strong argument that it's
morally preferable
to 30 years or 50 years or 100 years of
life in prison whatever
but also it's it's important to
think through these things in in our
society we want to pretend that death
doesn't exist
we want to pretend that people can be
president at 85 years old or whatever
we want to pretend that they won't have
lost a step that there's no such thing
as cognitive decline we want to pretend
that we will never die that we can put
off making decisions we can put off
marriage we can put off having kids we
can put off taking our career seriously
we can put off our education we can put
it all in all off because
in liberal society we want to pretend
that there's no no such thing as time
and we want to pretend there's no such
thing as death and we want to pretend
that through our progressive politics
we can actually eliminate germs we can
actually eliminate
disease we can even eliminate death and
that is simply not true
we are living in a fallen world this is
the reality of it
and there's nothing compassionate about
ignoring those realities
pretending that they don't exist
allowing cruel and cynical people
to run roughshod over our society
nothing
compassionate about that at all now that
point of view requires taking religion
seriously
and the left doesn't want to do that the
left thinks that's all superstition
well if you read the daily beast i i
think it's pretty clear
that secularists atheists are the most
superstitious people
on planet earth because they're they are
now
running a very important story from a
very important
expert who is a pet psychic
and wants to let the world know what joe
biden's pets think about the alleged
election of
their master which we'll get to in a
second but did you miss out on that
amazing black friday deal
let us relieve your fomo anxiety
today today only join us as a daily wire
member for 50
off with code dw50 over at dailywire.com
subscribe since last year's deal we have
added so many more features and products
to our membership program
we've added more exclusive readers past
content our insider and above members
can now stream our content on apple tv
and roku which is
huge because we're adding more content
every day such as
bringing you this very show five days a
week starting
this week starting this friday if you're
an all access member you can
get to join all access live our
exclusive daily live streams
with me or one of the other hosts where
we talk directly with you about
anything and more importantly steal your
ideas so that we can use them on the
shows
we may not be able to offer this deal
again next year so be sure to become a
member today
using coupon code dw50 over at
slash dailywire.com this deal was huge
on friday
we added lots and lots of new members
welcome to those of you who are joining
us for the first time today
we wanted to give you the opportunity
one last time this deal is unbelievable
we will not be running it again anytime
soon and probably
not ever dailywire.com subscribe we'll
be right back with a lot more
daily beast left wing website joe
biden's dogs have told this pet psychic
a lot about their beloved master
and his future i'll just read you the
first paragraph
pet psychic beth lee krauther says that
joe biden's dogs major in champ
told her they are excited to live in the
white house they also say
their master will be a great president
champ says he needs memory foam bedding
to ease problems with his joints major
thinks he may have dental problems both
dogs say joe biden's troubles with
donald trump
are far from over but that their master
is calm and focused enough to steer
america forward
the wisdom and prophecies of this pet
psychic go on
but i i think you get the point
the same people who tell you that
christianity is crazy
ridiculous so how nuts are you to
believe
the old fables in a book written by
illiterate goat herders or i don't know
whatever they say about the bible
the same people who tell you that's
crazy they believe this stuff
they run this stuff they do and even for
the people who
maybe they're just listening to the pet
psychic story as a kind of funny
sideshow but
they don't really take it seriously well
they might not take this seriously
but i bet they'll take maybe their
horoscope seriously i can't tell you how
many conversations i've been in
with friends of mine many friends of
mine
all over the country who really really
believe in the horoscopes
i mean they they'll they're avowed
atheists but they believe in the
horoscopes
or friends of mine who they think
going to church is crazy but they can't
miss their yoga session
because yoga they can't explain it but
it really centers their spirit
you know it gets all of their energy in
the right order it is
a liturgy for them i mean i've had
friends of mine say that yoga is their
church
and it is because yoga is a religious
liturgy whether we admit it or not
how many people do how many people take
if they say
well look i don't believe in any of that
hokey metaphysical stuff
but i eat this very special diet
because this very special diet not only
helps me lose weight but it just gets my
whole
body and spirit in order together so i'm
communing more appropriately with the
world all these kind of hokey things
which are usually
based on nothing all those fad-ish diets
do you remember a few years ago when
everyone suddenly had celiac disease
somehow the rates of celiac disease
increased by seven zillion percent
and even the people who were honest and
admitted they didn't have celiac disease
they said
well i i don't have celiac disease but i
still have a gluten
allergy i still i'm i still have gluten
sensitivity
and their their evidence for this was
that when they stopped stuffing their
face with bagels every day they felt
better
i must have a medical condition no i
think i think just stuffing your face
with bagels is not going to make you
feel great i say this is a man
who regularly stuffs his face with
bagels
that's i'm a new yorker this is the sort
of thing that we do all of these kind of
hokey theories
these hokey ideas the crystals i mean i
lived in los angeles
everyone talks about these the effects
of crystals and
incense and all this kind of nonsense
that is superstitious
that is part of a religious liturgy and
it is much crazier
than anything you will find in true
religion
the the irony here is that religious
people are the least superstitious
people i know
because they are grounding their beliefs
about the metaphysical world
in rigorous thought rigorous study
saint thomas aquinas was not a
superstitious man
he was one of the greatest logicians
we've ever had in our civilization
isn't i you often hear if you don't
stand for something you will fall for
anything
there's an irony that the it is the
irreligious who are the most
superstitious people
and speaking of religious conflict at
this point i think
the new york times must be trolling us
because if joe biden does ascend to the
presidency here's the sort of thing
you've got to look forward to
new york times writes iranian officials
who have always maintained that their
nuclear ambitions are for peaceful
purposes not weapons
expressed fury and vowed revenge
over the assassination of one of their
top nuclear scientists
calling it an act of terrorism and war
mongering
donald trump knows that if joe biden
becomes president
he's going to go really easy on the
iranians and put back in place that
awful iran deal
that led to madness in the middle east
unlike trump's policy
which stopped being so nice to iran and
led to a lot of peace in the middle east
so what donald trump is doing the
president goes in
and assassinates a top iranian nuclear
scientist
because nobody really believes that they
want a peaceful nuclear program they
obviously want to bomb
the new york times seems to admit this
too their ambitions are for peaceful
purposes
but they have fury and vowed revenge it
must be like how those protests over the
summer
were for peaceful purple they're mostly
peaceful nuclear ambitions
they're mostly they're protests really
when the when the bomb drops all that
while it's falling i guess that's going
to be
some sort of protest it is not an act of
terrorism by the way
to kill an iranian nuclear scientist an
iranian nuclear scientist is working
on behalf of the state obviously for
military purposes
an act of terrorism is when you target
civilians
to achieve a political goal this is
not even close to that you are targeting
someone who is working
for the state for military purposes
to achieve your own military and
political goal not terrorism at all not
warmongering
i don't think we need any lectures from
the new york times or from
joe biden or from barack obama or any of
the liberal establishment on
war-mongering donald trump has
the greatest record of peace in my
lifetime of any president
and the democratic predecessor
president and vice president obama and
biden both had a terrible record
also speaking of religion i had to bring
up this clip this might be my favorite
clip
from the entire thanksgiving weekend
we've been told that joe biden is a
devout catholic we've been told that
donald trump is a terrible horrible
sinner and awful man who doesn't know
anything
about the bible you remember he referred
to second corinthians as two corinthians
which by the way some people actually do
but anyway he was mocked for this he's
never read a bible in his life
you didn't see the same treatment when
joe biden over the weekend
referred to a book of the bible that i
i'm not familiar with
the book of palms and if we do
and i'm sure we can we can proclaim
the promised with the promise who wrote
these following words the lord is my
strength and my shield
the promised the promise wrote that
that's
i thought i had read at least a decent
number of books of the bible i guess i
had missed
the promise i think he might be
referring to the psalmist
no doubt joe biden will blame this on
his childhood stutter just like he
blames everything on his childhood
stutter which
magically disappeared from the age of
what seven to
75 and then that childhood stutter came
back again i think if it comes back at
75 it's not a childhood stutter anymore
i think it's an adult cognitive decline
but in this case i don't think it's that
joe biden is
in such decline that he forgets the book
of this bible that he's devoted to he's
not a devout catholic in any way
he supports abortion which is not
permissible and he supports abortion in
public life which is not permissible
that's why he was denied the eucharist
at mass
a number of months ago rightly denied
that joe biden ought to be
excommunicated
excommunication can be an act of mercy
this gets back i guess to our death
penalty conversation
justice can be an act of compassion
because the purpose of something like an
excommunication
or of this chiding is
to change the person's heart it's
rehabilitative
punishment can be a rehabilitative thing
we used to know that
you do this to say you are in a very
grave state you are
in imperiling your soul joe biden who
professes to be a devout catholic you
need to repent and change your views but
no one's forcing him to do that
which is uh much crueler to joe biden if
you actually believe
that catholic religion that he pretends
to believe he sues
nuns people who are devout catholics
don't sue nuns and people who are devout
catholics though they may not
have read every single word of the bible
i'm willing to grant that because
catholics read the bible liturgically
you read it as part of mass but sure
maybe they don't they haven't read every
word of it
they've read the psalms the psalms are
one of the most significant well-known
books of the bible
and i just don't think joe biden takes
any of that very seriously i think
that his true religion that he's devoted
to is secularism
i think that's the true religion of
virtually everybody on the left today
and it's a false religion and it's a
wicked religion for
our politics and it's going to lead to a
lot of misery and it's going to ruin a
lot of souls
in the life hereafter but it is a strong
religion and and we need to call it for
what it is
he is the potential president joe biden
another
another potential president actually the
current president right now donald trump
who does not get fawning articles about
his kitty cats
who does not get off the hook when he
mis-states books of the bible
donald trump actually gets less respect
maybe than anybody else in the entire
country
and recently during a press conference
some reporter starts mouthing off in a
way that's
degrading not only to the presidency but
especially degrading to this reporter
and president trump calls him out for it
he points out you know buddy whatever
you think of me
personally you are disrespecting the
office of the president
no i can't say that at all i think it's
a it's a possibility
they're trying to look between you
people don't answer don't talk to me
that way
you're just a you're just a lightweight
don't talk to me that way don't talk to
i'm the president of the united states
don't ever talk to the president that
way
all right i'm going to go with another
question go ahead absolutely right
and some people are going to attack
donald trump for this and say he is thin
skinned he's an egotist he's not an
egotist
i mean he's an egotist in the sense that
every politician is an egotist and trump
puts his name on buildings
but when it gets to the deeper question
of political humility or political
narcissism donald trump is much more
humble than barack obama
barack obama felt there was no end
to his ability to transform the world
through politics he described himself as
a sort of savior a messianic figure
who said that the earth would heal and
the oceans the sea levels would
lower upon his election donald trump
doesn't say that sort of thing
and if donald trump were a true
narcissist in this case he would say
don't ever talk to me like that i'm
donald trump
you can't talk to donald trump that way
donald trump is donald trump so what he
said
he said don't don't you talk to me that
way i'm the president of the united
states
don't you ever talk to the president of
the united states like this
whether that president is me whether
that president is somebody else
whether that president was barack obama
we didn't do this sort of thing during
the obama administration
worst thing anyone ever said to barack
obama was when that congressman yelled
out during the state of the union you
lie while barack obama was lying
and it was disrespectful sure but
compared to this stuff it's nothing
compared to this stuff that was child's
play republicans generally speaking were
very very respectful to obama
because as awful as he was and continues
to be
he was the president we have respect for
the office of the president we didn't
even impeach the guy when we could have
because he abused his power and
committed crimes
we didn't do it but that sort of
disrespect
continues with donald trump and it'll
happen to whoever the next guy is
the republicans who are pretending that
it's just donald trump that they're
after they're kidding themselves
you could put up a living saint maybe
especially if you put up a living saint
the left and the press and everybody
else would absolutely
eviscerate him we don't know
who the next president will be i know
that this is un unpleasant for us we
don't like to live in this state of
apprehension we want to know what's
happening well
life is the stuff of apprehension
and tension and unknowing we we just
don't know these things for certain
the left in particular wants to pretend
that they know exactly what's going to
happen forever because of their fatalist
religion of secularism
and the science of history and the
science of politics and they
want to pretend that they know the right
side of history and the utopia we're all
going to get to
and how it's all going to work out we
don't
we don't we we know the state of things
in the courts
doesn't look particularly great for
trump he's had a few victories here and
there
contrary to what the media have told you
he has presented evidence
his team has presented evidence of
outright crimes and certainly of matters
of fraud and irregularities
is that enough to overcome this hurdle
to decertify the votes that have already
been certified
to convince electors not to vote for
trump doesn't seem particularly likely
but there's two weeks left
do not give up do not give up because
what's the point of giving up
i know there are a lot of people who say
trump's just got to concede he's got to
leave if trump gives up right now first
of all
anything that he's trying to iron out
before he leaves office that's off the
table
any appointments he's trying to get
through any deals he's trying to cut
with our adversaries and our
our allies that's not going to work well
and
why if he gives up right now what
happens to all those legal challenges
that are potentially exposing fraud and
in some cases have
exposed serious evidence those would go
away
we would gain nothing we would lose
quite a lot
there is no reason to get even if the
chances are that we don't prevail in the
end
there is no reason to give up right now
the only people trying to get you to
give up
are the ones who very likely didn't want
to support
donald trump in the first place they're
trying to discourage you don't be
discouraged
be encouraged have heart there is
quite a lot going on at the at the
physical level at the metaphysical level
everywhere in between and if the time
may come that we only get news stories
about fluffy the cat
for the next four years so be it but
until then we ought to keep fighting i'm
michael noel since the michael knowles
shall see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
assistant director pavel wadowski editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva and
production assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 2020.
you know the matt wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about i
hope you'll give it a listen
you